hey welcome to fat man beyond
i'm kevin smith i am mark bernard
hey how are you kids uh we're still
quarantining of course
in separate places even though we live
in the same city
it's i don't know if you've caught the
news but uh our
somebody the governor the mayor somebody
said there's not a single icu bed left
so we're yeah we're playing it safe even
though
we relatively trust each other and
whatnot but
we're saying we i did see the stats that
uh that la county seems to be
the the hot spot in the word county
of the worst state in the word country
or pelvic we're ground zero they said
they're calling us ground zero right now
what was new york
at the beginning of the quarantine when
we all felt bad like oh my god poor new
york
we have now surpassed new york
right here in our own backyard and um it
has
affected uh not just my travel to go
like
to the [ __ ] scum and villainy cantina
uh and meet with mark and jc and andrew
would do a show
it has also affected my ability to go
see my mom on her birthday i didn't get
to go do that last week
didn't get to go to the opening of
movies in minnesota in minneapolis which
sold out but thank you but still i
didn't get to go
we debuted a giant [ __ ] suit there
mark
like a big booby costume spent a pretty
penny to make it with the people that
make the mass singer costumes i don't
even get to
[ __ ] enjoy it and [ __ ] i know this is
the the lamest
of covid complains there are people like
i've lost relatives bro
but you know we we can't do much i'm not
now i'm not going to dallas to see my
kid over christmas
no no it doesn't know this will be the
first christmas since the kid
come out the shoot that i won't be
looking at her
you know yeah so it's we're
in a world where none of that's going on
me and mark
are in separate places and whatnot
protecting our brood
protecting jc's brand new brood and
whatnot
and protecting ourselves we're
middle-aged [ __ ] men for god's sakes
mid-laid men with pre-existing
conditions yeah
this [ __ ] virus is hunting for us
like the terminator
and me and mark are a couple of john
connors trying to
maybe not john connors we're sarah
connors trying to duck
it's this [ __ ] terrible killing thing
and uh
duck it and so we can have a future man
apparently we have kids that save the
world
so uh
it went from i think this the stats were
something like one in 2500 people
um had covid as recently as november
and now it's one in i heard like 25.
yeah it's even lower now in los angeles
it's something like 1 in 20 where it's
like oh my god that's getting closer and
closer
now i'm starting to look at my wife all
such she never leaves the house and i'm
still like
can i trust you did you go get the mail
who got the mail
and still the uh you know we're i guess
the
vaccine is starting with people that
need it the most but
this feels like you know matt that
moment in jaws
when robert shaw is telling the story
about the indianapolis he's like you
know that's the scared
the most scared i was the whole time
i'll never put out a life jacket again
like we know rescue is coming
it's not quite here yet and it's like
will the sharks eat us before they get
us up
out of the [ __ ] water and that big
fat pby is hovering over us
young fella young like mr hooper here
herbie
herbie cooper herbie robinson chief
robinson from cleveland he bobbed up and
down in the water like a kind of top
you'd been upended
like a i ended up that's my favorite
part of it i saw some [ __ ] on twitter
where i got i don't know some british
magazine either
empire or total film somebody wrote some
sort of [ __ ]
thing piece and said like jaws ain't all
that and it was like
oh another 24 year old who just saw a
movie
has some feelings and it's like bro
like just i don't know many things
in life to be true but jaws i know
is indeed all that
it still holds up we were just [ __ ]
quoting it
and we we're didn't even come across
like how to touch irrelevant old men
because jaws is always right there in
the public consciousness man
primarily charts what's his name
um how have you been sir uh i've been
good man i've been good this has been um
i'm trying to remember what this last
week was this last week was a lot of uh
end of year meetings business stuff like
the industry town tends to shut down
christmas week and doesn't open up again
until after new year's so there's a lot
of like hey can we can we get a quick
zoom in hey can we can you
turn this in hey we gotta we gotta send
you off
to write this thing and so it's been
really busy um
all good things um nothing nothing in
any way that made me
um that's so disappointed that's like oh
man i didn't get that
i've had enough of i didn't get that
this was a
you're you're you're primed to try to
get this
which is a pretty good place to be how
can i
man i uh i spent all this week
uh uh me and uh eric our buddy eric
carrasco who's written a
supergirl episodes that i've directed
he's been on fat man beyond and also of
course he's one of our
co-writers on masters of the universe uh
colon revelations coming to netflix in
2021
which excites me because i remember
doing powercon
not last year you know during [ __ ]
covid but the year before when we
announced it we were all there and [ __ ]
like that
and there's so much energy in the room
and i was like i'll see you [ __ ] in
2020
and mattel was like 2021.
and i was like what it's 2019 what are
you talking about and
like takes a long time to do this [ __ ]
dude it takes a year to make cartoons
and i was like i
i did 20 21. well now we're coming up to
2021 finally
we are i although it makes me wonder if
mattel knew something
or they're like listen man you're not
going to be back here in 2020.
yeah i don't i can't tell you why
[ __ ] they they might have a they
might have a conduit into the future
maybe they knew some [ __ ] let me tell
you something honestly like 2020 has
been like a
[ __ ] year as we all know but my happy
place
honestly has been that masters universe
series
like because when we were done for the
most part
like you know all the writing had been
done by the time i got to like
finish with the jane zombob reboot
roadshow tour
that was it but this i've never been
involved with a [ __ ] project like
this i mean we did the clerk's cartoon
years ago and stuff
um but like you know i guess when we did
jay and sal and bob's super groovy
cartoon movie it was like this
i forgot there's this this
rainfall or or waterfall effect
of satisfaction that comes with
something that's
going to be produced away from you like
you know normally in my world i write a
thing
and then i direct a thing and then i cut
a thing and then you know i'm i'm living
with this [ __ ] thing forever
i can't draw for [ __ ] i'm not an
animation director
so pat and um adam are our two directors
one night
they take our scripts and then
periodically
like throughout 2020 they're like here's
an animatic
or here's a fully animated cartoon and
so
like every other week i guess it was
you know just when like it was like man
[ __ ] can this
year get any worse boom motu would pop
up and be like here's something to make
you feel better
and like i get lost in the animatics and
the animation and it's such a wonderful
world where the characters like really
give a [ __ ] about each other
and and also they're like it's such an
epic adventure
and and and so you know the story just
really
engrosses me and i know where it's going
like i'll sit there and [ __ ] be like
i hope it works out for these
[ __ ] people and i'm like i know
exactly what's gonna happen
it's just so [ __ ] good so that has
been my
happy place and stuff um but this week
wasn't a motu week although i did see
episode five what they call first take
that means the full animation before
powerhouse gets in and [ __ ] with the
lighting and makes any corrections and
it's so [ __ ] good i i said it before
on the show i saw mark's episode which
is three and that's so [ __ ] good
five uh they're all [ __ ] wonderful
five was written by
eric and it's like it it's just plays
like a movie there's a lot of things
that kind of happen
it's oh but it looks so [ __ ] good
so that that was enjoyable this week um
but i had an outline to get done
this weekend for somebody entirely
different for something i haven't talked
about yet and i'm gonna keep
quiet until i know that it's happening
or not happen like if they're like this
ain't never going to happen then i'll be
like oh my god let me tell you what
almost [ __ ] happened
but um if it happens then i'll be like
oh my god i can't [ __ ] believe this
is going to happen let me tell you all
about it
so me and eric did this outline and uh
tag team back and forth like
all week and uh just turned it in
today made a big like whole thing was
great and and perfect and then we made a
big
[ __ ] change right before we submitted
it
um that was like a change that kind of
ran through the whole thing you had to
go from top
and fix all the way down so it gave me
one last opportunity to walk through the
outline which is like 17 pages single
spaced
and it's it's good like i'm happy as
[ __ ] with it like i was like you know
what this
[ __ ] work and if if they're like this
is or
[ __ ] it'll never work i i die on the
cross of like well that's
what i think it would be and if not like
don't worry about me whatsoever
uh but fingers crossed man so we just
turned it in
uh this morning and uh you know i
probably won't hear nothing about it
till after the holidays
yeah everybody would like you to get
done right before the holidays but
nobody's gonna make any decisions
until after you know new year's and
stuff like that so
that's i woke up early like to do that
like when i'm in a
wonderful writing space like if
five o'clock in the morning we'll roll
around i'll wake up because i
just want to get back into that world
whatever it is i'm writing if i'm so
into it
so i got up this morning at five and i
was like oh my god i'm going back into
that that was [ __ ] fun
and i worked from five until one o'clock
this afternoon and then
submitted it and stuff so i point of the
story is
i have i have been remiss i have not
showered in three days thank god we're
not dealing with each other thank god
you can probably see the stink lines
rising off of me
um i apologize to uh i've been doing
cameos over at cameo
for uh all the money we use to rebuild
the secret stash because we're
rebuilding jay and style bob secret
stash down the street
so for like three days while i've been
[ __ ]
up the ass of this outline i let my
cameos like slip so i apologize if
anybody was like i tried to get a
[ __ ] cameo and it expired when you
didn't send a video
i will definitely get back to them if
you want to resubmit and stuff but
do you ever get that when you're just in
the writing place and you're like
everything else has to
[ __ ] off i took a break yesterday two
times to
stream one was with jay because he asked
me to come over and stream on his twitch
channel and we opened up these masters
universe figures that mondo makes which
are like
unfucking believably beautiful crazy
right
and then at night i hosted uh uh
over ign for uh tiltify it was called
steve buscemi um has a charity he loves
called friends of firefighters that he
was doing a fundraiser for
um and it was with like everybody
who's still around from the sopranos
um and it was nuts like you know [ __ ]
jersey orgy
um without even leaving this room all on
the laptop seeing like some of the most
famous [ __ ] people you know because
i've watched that show a number of
[ __ ] times as says the world and
stuff
so i took time to do that that was like
really cool i got to kind of fanboy out
and
and uh and we raised like a hundred
grand for the fireman's fund
that's amazing pretty sweet i mean you
know you got the entire sopranos cast
and also
david chase was there uh terence winter
had written a new scene
and they did a reading it was almost
like the full cast
reading of first new sopranos material
since the show went off the air over 10
years ago
um so i you know as soon as i was done
with that
boom i went back into the writing like i
was writing right up until i had to jump
on the zoom to do that and as soon as
done boom i went right back into the
outline
do you when you go hard like that like
and not about beating a deadline but
when you like
love what you're doing do you find that
where you're like i'll wake the [ __ ] up
early and [ __ ] like that
um i yes but on the other side i never
wake up early to do things guy i may
i'll stay up as late as it takes to keep
going
so my my writing ends up no now it's a
little bit different but let's let's
pretend that i'm on a job
where i'm in a room not related to
whatever i'm writing from nine to five
then i'm going home and i'll be with my
family for a bit
and then people start like dropping off
at around 10 30
and then i will start writing at about
11 and i'll write
if you know if i'm okay about it until
like 12 30 one
but if i'm in it if i'm in that hill if
i'm if i'm on the downhill
of it then i could be up until three
o'clock in the morning
you know because the just the motor of
it it becomes this like perpetual
energy machine where like you can keep
going because it keeps feeding you and
you've got another thing and
i can see the end and it's that's that's
that's the reason why i do it at the end
of the day is that
feeling of oh no i'm just barely holding
on
i'm no longer having to like grind this
[ __ ] out it's not the beginning
it's the end right that's my favorite
part
i do i love that sense completion where
you're like ah that was today when i
turned it in
i i shouldn't have done this but like
old habits are hard to break i was like
i'm gonna order a bunch of [ __ ]
food because i deserve that you know i
used food as a celebration you're not
really supposed to do that when you're
my type of person
and uh you know but i couldn't i was
just such a like
you know like this was this was
everything
it took so what long and now it's
it's done and [ __ ] i'm gonna i need
solely
[ __ ] louisiana vegan food um
so i i indulged like that and whatnot um
but yeah
it was a writing week is that a friend
who a writing said
you know who gave me this advice which i
which i found it kind of helpful
but like when you when you turn
something in if it's big when you finish
something especially if you're getting
paid for it
but like when you turn in that thing and
that check shows up like buy yourself
something
like doesn't have to be big you know or
it can be big like you want to buy
yourself a new car
do it you want to buy yourself a nice tv
do it but
some semblance of the the risk reward
is good to kind of reinforce but i'm at
the point where the things that i would
do
i can't do but i don't need a new car
like i'd love to go out for a really
nice dinner i'd love to you know
grow a tiny baby party i'd love to you
know buy around the drinks for people at
a bar
um can't do any of that so yes grubhub
gets the like hey you know what i'd
really like
yeah oh my god there's this place
i don't even know what's it called
[ __ ] i don't like i don't even know
because i just
you know you order on the app so you
look at the picture and [ __ ] like that
but
we order from there almost every day and
they make these
cookies dorothy's vegan cookies let me
tell you man dorothy
has made a lot of [ __ ] money off me
my my fat ass i've been ordering these
cookies they make these chocolate chip
cookies and these
peanut butter chip cookies they're vegan
they're so [ __ ] good
so every day like we wind up ordering
them and ordering them and i wonder
about these
like folks like that run their
businesses and
and send out food via postmates do you
think they
like notice like these [ __ ] again
or is it just a series of numbers and
[ __ ]
i think i may order enough for them to
like take notice where they're like
he he we may have to cut him off he's
got a problem or something
i think if he ordered directly from the
place they might like
the post mates i kind of feel turns it
into this weird
like binary digits and faceless
algorithms but if you just call them
you'll be like hey
you know what i want i've been like yeah
yeah that was like veggie grill when i
was going to veggie grill i was like the
norm of [ __ ]
cheers they're like kev how's it going
miss kev i'm like
[ __ ] going vegan i don't have i'm not
a good writer that's why i didn't win an
emmy for cheers mark obviously i just
showed you
i'm not i don't have cheers chops i
didn't come up with a fast enough norm
peterson joke
most of the audience like who the [ __ ]
is norm peterson it's very old comedy
kids
check it out uh the chat's going wild uh
mark because
all anyone wants to talk about
is bib fortuna no they want to talk
about
so many things that happened in the
season finale
of uh of the uh the mandalorian and so
we should dive into that
uh but first uh we got a sponsor kids
we're always delighted
and honored and and happy uh and and
really shocked
when anybody chooses fat man beyond
to advertise on because we're like
what's our demographic
what does an advertiser look at me and
mark
and say you know what i can sell through
these guys
like it's always interesting to me um
and apparently when people look at me
and mark they're like
hair replacement those guys i look at
them
and i think middle age i think i think
they're losing their hair
what could they do about that sort of
thing man
and the good folks it keeps remember
them
the good folks at keeps they
co-sponsored last week's show
the good folks at keeps man they look at
me and mark
and they know that they could trust
their product in our hands man because
we believe
in keeping as much [ __ ] hair as we
possibly can
when we were young bucks hair going down
the shower drain we didn't care
you bought clumps of that [ __ ] man when
we were in our emo
days thought we'd have hair to spare
forever and then one day that ain't the
case man how do you keep what you got
left
you use keeps tell them mark you know
two out of three guys will experience
some form of male pattern baldness
by the time they're 35 and the best way
to prevent hair loss is to do something
about it
while you still have that hair left and
you have to go to a doctor's office for
your hair loss prescription but now
thanks to keeps you can visit a doctor
online and get hair loss medication
delivered right to your home
easy delivery medication every three
months so you can say goodbye to
pharmacy checkout lines and awkward
doctor visits
uh prevention is key folks keeps
treatments
uh typically take between four to six
months to see results so it's important
that you act
fast man the sooner you start using
keeps the more hair you'll save just
makes absolute sense it's math
ladies and gentlemen find out why keeps
has more five-star reviews than any of
its competitors
and more than 100 000 men
trust keeps for their hair loss
prevention
medication man keeps treatment start at
just
10 bucks a month that's cheap plus for a
limited time
10 bucks a month i can't afford not to
do this mark plus for a limited time you
can get your first
month free free box
so if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
fat man f-a-t-m-a-n to receive your
first month of treatment
for free that's k-e-e-p-s s
dot com slash fat man
um i yeah please do it number one do it
because
without hair like you can't get [ __ ]
done in this world
do you ever see a ball the only bald
person gets [ __ ] done lex luthor
and jeff bezos same guy from all up for
all week
um if i if i could uh
if i have one regret in this life mark
two regrets
one is not taking every cent of that
clerks and mall rats money
and sticking it into storage facilities
oh i'd be a [ __ ] rich man right now
and the other truck
no storage facilities that's where the
real money is everyone's got this
country's so full of [ __ ] everyone's got
to rent places to stick it whatnot so
i wish i'd done that number two i wish
i'd kept more of my hair
keeps came along a little too late for
for to save
uh the hair that i lost but they're
gonna help me keep the hair that i got
right now man
if i go to keeps.com k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash fat man
uh keeps ladies and gentlemen the good
folks at keeps are proud sponsors
of uh fat man beyond uh if you like us
and you like your hair go to keeps.com
slash fat man like the man he said tell
me and mark sent you right let's see if
chat
is was offended by that commercial nope
they're just
all they're doing is talking about
mandalorian they don't even need us
they're they're they're joined in the
chat getting deep into the conversation
for heaven's sake so it's like we just
we're running a storage facility and we
just opened the door
and they're just having a grand old time
don't [ __ ]
tease me by saying storage facility man
i couldn't
i could have bent somebody man before we
dive into the mandalorian can i show you
uh something like one day they're gonna
fire me dead
in this room and people are gonna be
like murdered
and people are gonna be like what was
the murder weapon and
it's gonna be this look at how
[ __ ] thick as a dick
this book is dude it's the grant
morrison
uh jla absolute edition i read about it
on twitter
because somebody was there's an article
somewhere about how they took the
artwork an old
howard i think it's a howard porter
piece of artwork yeah an old howard
porter cover from like an old
uh i think it compiled three issues and
they
changed like martian manhunter's cape
they removed half of it
so the article was like why the [ __ ]
would they do that there's an
interesting article but what i got most
out of the article is
there's a [ __ ] grant morrison
absolute edition
so i ordered that [ __ ] on amazon and it
came
and it is it's heavy dude this is one of
the heaviest books i've ever seen and
look at all the material i paid cash
money for this man some people like send
me free [ __ ] like we talk about it
but i'm paying cash money this is a
hundred and fifty dollars i mean
i bought it on amazon so i'm sure i got
it cheaper but
you could you could kill a human being
with this much
creative writing i mean if your dick is
that thick you need to register with the
police
tell me about it oh look at that ooh ooh
it's got one of my favorite comic book
stories ever published
rock of ages that's in there as well
um is beautiful beautiful
tome to have man and uh when it came
my wife was like they sent you another
free book i said the same free i paid
for it and she said you [ __ ]
that's how i know is money well spent
my wife is like why would you do that
and i'm like
i knew it i knew there was i wanted this
book
um okay man wait was alec byrd says do
we tell kevin he should have brought it
from his own comic book store
what an excellent point man but i'll be
honest with you
amazon ships faster than jane's album
secret stash
and i had to have this book immediately
he's absolutely right though for all
your for all your
hardcover jla needs go to
jadeansonbob.com or jane sombop secret
stash
while you still have a chance man
december 28th the old stash
closes her doors forever and then uh in
the first week of january
the new stash opens her brand new doors
just down the street and whatnot ernie
o'donnell building it right now you can
see videos about it on my youtube
channel
it looks phenomenal one side of the
place looks like
chronic the other side of the place
looks like blunt man in colors
um so yes so support the secret stash
unlike the guy who owns the secret stash
buy all your [ __ ] there
that that's an absolutely great [ __ ]
point man god damn it
i'm also a local bookstore yeah they
really here i am going like amazon
they're the key and they're like you're
a [ __ ] local comic shop idiot
i'm like you're right yeah go to the
stash um
i i wasn't thinking my bad it's all good
uh should we should we get into it
should we should we give the people what
they want
we should i just before we dive into it
um did you hear we'll we'll go through
an
order but during the last there was a
scene
i forget where it was but somebody said
[ __ ] mcclunky
yes it was in the it was in the the
final mos
eisley and almost like the the tattooing
yes that's what i thought i thought i
heard
and i was like well done
there you know i saw an article today
online which another like [ __ ]
article where i'm like who's
writing this [ __ ] where somebody was
like is there too much fan
service in the mandalorian i'm like [ __ ]
no
and shut up like don't be starting that
talk where all of a sudden it maybe
manifests and like
us getting less moments like we've had
in like all this season
i saw some people going like yeah last
season they didn't do so much fan
service i'm like
yeah and that's why i love this season
[ __ ] more this [ __ ] is making me
a star wars fan again in a big bad way
man and like
it i didn't have to go far it wasn't a
deep journey but like
this is star wars perfected for heaven's
sakes
um of course there are going to be
references to the past god damn better
there better be but i don't hear any of
this [ __ ] is there too much fan
service
oh i think what mandalorian did really
well was
they earned it you know like they
invested you in these new characters
that you've never seen before
that you're like oh okay what's this guy
about and [ __ ] baby yoda sure let's
go on this ride
and so by the time like if you had
gotten
both the tan and ahsoka tano in the
first two episodes of the first season
and they've been like oh well what is
this [ __ ] like i
i'm here for this guy but then also
these two people are crazy interesting
and now
like so by the time you get to the end
of this season
and we've given you know at this point
10 12 hours of our lives to it and then
you get
[ __ ] luke skywalker then you get r2
then you get all this stuff
it's they worked for it they earned it
they just didn't because you could have
absolutely
started with that [ __ ] and they're like
oh yeah no no i get it it's the show
it's like
force awakens the series where just
we're giving you all this stuff without
really earning it
they earned it and i'm on board for it
oh you're not kidding uh first off folks
if you're
sitting in and watching the show uh it
goes without saying spoilers we're gonna
talk
and spoil the [ __ ] out of the season
finale not only the season finale of the
mandalorian but
probably be talking about previous
episodes of the mandalorian so if you
don't want any of this [ __ ] spoiled for
you
close your ears or go someplace else and
watch it after you've seen it um
mark hamill's instagram yes yes but
although to be fair i was
like it's so strange
after the episode was done
i rewatched it again and i'd seen the
you know end credit piece um but during
the credits
themselves i had been i was tweeting
about like my reaction to the show
and it hadn't occurred to me until the
second viewing
to see who played the jedi you know
where i was like oh
well i i wonder
and you know [ __ ] sure enough
we saw a name in blue
in those credits man i mean in my mind
they're blue i think they're still blue
um we saw we saw is it
we saw his name connected um
with that other name that we like love
so much
i i i was i could not believe it
like you know around the bar
and uh pre that episode airing
you know we were all talking and jc was
like
i think we did it on the show jc is like
i'm [ __ ] i bet the house on it being
ezra
and i was like you know that makes sen i
mean what are they going to do they
can't there's only so many jedi's they
could do we've already met ahsoka
um you know they can't do luke scott
walker because
and and that's right there i should have
stopped
because i'm such a literal list going
well they can't use mark luke skywalker
because
and you know somewhere john favreau was
like
[ __ ] you of course it's gonna be luke
skywalker are you kidding me
he's like because that would be the
greatest thing ever what i love about
the mandalorian is it's like going over
to
favro's house and watching him play with
star wars figures
and he's so good at it that you don't
even feel the need to jump in
you're not like well can i be a storm
trooper you're like you just keep doing
it bro
like i understand now why people watch
other people play video games on twitch
i was always like you know god that must
be so frustrating because playing video
games is fun if i watch somebody play a
video game i'm just going to want to do
it myself
but when i watch the mandalorian it does
not make me want to make mandalorian
it does not make me go oh i want to do
that like if anything
it makes me want to pull out toys and
[ __ ] play and stuff like that but i
am
more than content to watch john favreau
[ __ ] play and in this week's episode
he had a major assist of course by the
director peyton reed who
brought it on yet again um
i'm telling you man that's how good that
[ __ ] is sometimes i watch things and i'm
like
it kicks my creative gear off where i'm
like
what are you watching this [ __ ] for you
can make [ __ ] go make something go write
something
i don't feel that way after mandalorian
i i don't watch it it doesn't make me go
like oh i want to make something
it makes me go like [ __ ] that's
that's awesome it reduces me to like a
member of the audience who almost
forgets that you know i know how to do
this [ __ ] too
like i may not make [ __ ] like the
mandalorian but i also make filmed
entertainment not like this anymore but
you know what i'm saying like
however we [ __ ] shoot it i don't pay
much attention in the cinematography
mark obviously
but like in a world where like i know
how the sausage is made
to be able to [ __ ] appreciate savor
and want more sausage from some other
[ __ ] chef even though you know
it's just [ __ ] ground-up pork with
[ __ ] spices
how different can it be the guy makes
great sausage
i will watch him [ __ ] play star wars
from now
until the end of time i loved watching
him play with his marvel figures
when he made iron man and i remember
when they first announced like they're
doing a new trilogy and [ __ ]
at first i was like they should get
[ __ ] favro man iron man's like
practically the new star wars and [ __ ]
and then of course you know it was jj
and ryan and then jj who did great jobs
but
thank god they got around to like
yeah go john what do you got and he was
like oh let me show you and pulled out
his gigantic
sarlacc pit sized [ __ ] [ __ ]
and started showing us like beautiful
things
take dude takes me on a [ __ ] time
travel uh journey right back to my
childhood i was so emotionally [ __ ]
involved
like you know once that they're all
[ __ ] trapped on the bridge and
you hear like the beep beep beep beep
and they're like what's that and
you know you're like all right someone's
coming to a rescue and you see a [ __ ]
x-wing
and you're like well nah now there's no
that's the magic of it because the
audience is like
they wouldn't do that like it could it
be but it's an x-wing who else
is the next wing you know is it leia is
it
i don't [ __ ] know okay and then like
he walks through and then you see the
green lightsaber you're like
what come on though is it it was so
beautifully spaced with the thing the
belt buckle the [ __ ] like
the all black octagonal belt buckles
it was almost like he was like what was
i wearing in jedi oh yeah i'll put that
it was um like seeing the
you know first you see the [ __ ] uh
the
the him in the giant cape it reminds you
right of return of the jedi
of him coming into jabba's palace
because that [ __ ] luke
skywalker is the same
[ __ ] luke skywalker was like you will
bring captain solo on the wookie to me
like all [ __ ] authority all business
and a full-fledged [ __ ] jedi so
number one
you watch him [ __ ] like effortlessly
take people out
and they do that thing that only started
with
george and the prequels where everyone's
scared of jedi's
where they're like that's a [ __ ] jedi
and everybody gets like nervous and [ __ ]
like at one point he's like open the
door and she's like what are you crazy
like i love that they turn jedis into
like shogun warriors that everybody even
the good guys are [ __ ] afraid of
because they're like because now they're
rare
because there's only like a [ __ ]
handful of them left
and so they become legend and and myth
and something to be either revered or
feared
or both which is kind of great but yeah
that the last 10 minutes of that episode
is like perfect suspense cinema
like because it's just reversal after
reversal after rehearsal it's like all
right
he reflected the dark troopers out okay
great and then he then the [ __ ] big
fight and whatever and he gets the dark
saber but the whole thing on the bridge
where it's
you know who the [ __ ] is coming the dark
troopers are back and they're just
marking through
and they're at the door and you just
hear the [ __ ] thud of the fits on the
door
then you see the x-wing and then it's
like oh what the [ __ ] gonna happen now
and then oh my god
and then it's do we let them in like
it's all of these tiny little clips and
changes and it's all
visceral and it's all genetic it's not
there's not a lot of dialogue there
at all it's true oh no it's all cinema
that's cinematic as [ __ ] that whole
sequence and
lord the [ __ ] favro understands
that this [ __ ] community loves a
hallway
scene because you know they they [ __ ]
took
one of the most you know and it's only
recent but one of the most famous
[ __ ] hallway scenes of all time
and said did you like what his dad did
remember what his dad did
watch his [ __ ] son and then you know
it's like
watching repeat but but you know
you're like yay like when you watched
vader
in rogue one you were like that rocks
but you were like holy [ __ ]
space hitler is good at his job for the
first time in these movies
but when you watch this and [ __ ] luke
is just you know murdering
and [ __ ] destroying uh dark troopers
it's all like emotional like
yeah as you you saw him first in black
and white
and look lightsaber snaps on
but you don't see the color and then you
know when they're all in the room and
they're like it's a jedi
and they cut to that shot where suddenly
the [ __ ] lightsaber just the green
comes right into the foreground and [ __ ]
that was when i lost it that was when i
started crying that's when if john
favreau was here
i would have embarrassed myself like in
sobbing and
collapsing into his arms what a
beautiful
[ __ ] beat they i'm not taking
anything away
from any of the people that made the
movies and whatnot i love i loved all
the star wars movies
um and i thought ryan johnson did a
great job
um i thought his showdown with luke
skywalker and kylo ren was [ __ ] dope
but you know i i also talked about like
when i reviewed the movie years ago like
yeah i get it like i understand it's
important that he's not there because
the legend grows and that shows he's
even more [ __ ] powerful that he was
able to
project himself across a galaxy but i
loved his one line where he's just like
what am i gonna do stand there with a
laser sword and take on the entire
empire myself and [ __ ]
and so you know as you watch last jedi
you're like yeah
you know i guess that's i thought i
wanted that but you're right i don't
want that this is cooler
this [ __ ] sequence was
that was essentially like no luke
skywalker is a
[ __ ] lethal the most destructive
[ __ ] jedi that ever lived
and it's him this ain't a forced
projection
this is him at his peak jedi this man
has just years before toppled the
[ __ ] galactic empire
and killed the emperor of course this
motherfucker's gonna take out
dark troopers of course like he [ __ ]
scoffs at the idea of [ __ ] uh
facing him off gideon and going to
rescue grogoo and stuff like that
he is the ultimate perfected jedi at
this point
and it fits so perfectly because
mandalorian is the ultimate perfected
star wars
at this point man they take all that's
good about star wars and all the things
that
make you go yeah and make you cheer even
when you're [ __ ]
50 years old and they just keep layering
it on with new stuff this ain't old
stuff
man it's taking wonderful elements
familiar elements and remixing and
creating new situations
while referencing classic cinema
classic western cinema classic eastern
cinema as well it's a thing of joy man
and i
i never once look at it and and go
well this is what i would do like i'm
reduced to utter fan
i would make no different choices it
[ __ ] destroys me whenever i read
people online
talking about like oh they should have
done this i'm like you
[ __ ] nuts they're giving us something
beautiful and you've got a [ __ ] like
you got some
extra ass and [ __ ] here one thing i'll
say
you know as he as [ __ ] luke tore
through all those dark troopers
yes i would have enjoyed hearing you
know
the [ __ ] you know the your group john
williams tragedy score
of course but this score was actually
kind of dope
and meditative and also had this
gravitas
to it like you know that's like a theme
of high adventure and [ __ ]
this guy didn't come for high adventure
this guy literally came to like i'm
going destroy evil
and i'm gonna take this good thing back
with me and i'm gonna train it to be a
jedi and [ __ ] like that
so there don't need to be like [ __ ]
happy music and [ __ ]
he's sad there was a somber tone to that
music as this guy's like
i'm still dealing with [ __ ] imperials
these [ __ ] [ __ ] are still out
here he's like oh well
and there's also the feeling that that
luke still has some of his father in him
you know like and if you watch those two
scenes kind of back to back there vader
in the hallway
at uh in rogue one and luke in the
hallway in this one
some of the moves are the same somebody
like i'm going to crush this thing
i'm going to lift you up and pulling you
across the room like they're still for
as
good and and wonderful as luke phil
walker is there's a dark side in him
that's real
and like when he lets it out like yeah
you can see how that guy
will eventually get to a point where he
realizes he can't be that guy anymore
you know and he has to change his ways
and you have to open a school and he has
to
eventually live on a [ __ ] island
somewhere because he doesn't trust
himself
and the power anymore and and the
beginning of that
feels like it's right here like all of
these lines connect
and there was a real sadness to that
that that weirdly conflicted with the
joy
of like is that [ __ ] luke skywalker
and look what happened to luke skywalker
in a way
you know it's not younglings and dark
papers are robots and so he's not
massacring [ __ ] but he's
ruthless in a way that we've never quite
seen luke skywalker before
which is exciting but also kind of
petrifying
um i taking it back to the start
in the opening sequence um where the
imperial
is doing the you know the standoff and
he's got his the gun to pershing's head
and stuff and he's like
he notices her cara dunes dunes
tear and says oh you know something
about alderaan
and then you know she was like oh yeah i
was i i saw your planet destroyed i was
on the death star and she's like which
one
and he's looks like you know he gets all
shitty where he's like that's not
[ __ ] funny
and he starts talking about all the
people
that died on those what he calls those
two bases
and it's the second time in as many
weeks
where they humanize the
empire in a way that you've never seen
before
last week with the transport trucks
there was like when they got the one
truck through this [ __ ]
little ragtag group of imperials were
like yeah and they're partying and [ __ ]
and there's a human face to their
victory and
this week there's a human base face to
you know the the the talk about the
death star the inference that
those people were murdered and he used
the word like
terrorists as well he was like it was
destroying alderaan was a small price to
pay for wiping out
terrorism or something like that now
number one as the guy you know who wrote
the scene in clerks about [ __ ]
innocent death star contractors getting
killed
we're in my era of star wars now mark
where people are asking the important
questions you know
questions that i've been waiting a
quarter of a century to get answers to
and [ __ ] like
uh but i do enjoy this like and i'm not
saying you know
[ __ ] there are good people on both
sides not at all but i do
enjoy this humanization moments
of the imperials rather than like these
just faceless like we're [ __ ] bad and
i mean let's be honest
most of the empire is completely [ __ ]
faceless because they're all wearing
like masks and [ __ ] like that and the
worst armor that has ever been devised
by people who can travel through space
and and and they just like somebody put
it on like
because we talked about it on last
week's episode and i saw somebody on
twitter i wish i'd remember who it was
um but it was really i said oh that's
pretty insightful
they said why that's happening and why
that's special
is because for your entire life
you have seen stories about the empire
who always won because you know they
were [ __ ] massive
and this little ragtag bunch of rebels
who had the piss and vinegar to pull it
together and [ __ ]
take the empire down and [ __ ] he's like
now it's role reversal
the empire are these ragtag
[ __ ] remainders that are trying to
keep their [ __ ] thing going
fighting against the new republic and
whatnot so they're like the person said
on twitter
you're seeing like victory they never
had to celebrate victories before
because they just destroyed they would
blow up [ __ ] planets so it's like
it's not like they all sat around go
like we did it like we had the most
firepower
but as they're faced with dwindling
numbers and defeat and whatnot
the tiniest of victories they're
celebrating or
in the case of the opening of this
week's show there's this
sense of humanity and loss to the bad
guys where like you know you get the
impression
that that [ __ ] dude who she shot in
the face
lost friends on one or if not both of
the death stars and [ __ ] like that
it's interesting to layer in there you
know
it's a nice dimension it's yeah it's
it's about perspective
right like there would absolutely be
propaganda
on both sides of the war and there
always is you know the
the either the axis powers or the allies
or whoever it is will automatically
build a narrative explaining the reasons
why the other side is bad
you know and if you're the empire even
if when you were blowing up planets
i'm sure that the narrative was these
are terrorists who are coming to
to threaten our way of life and in order
to keep the empire great to make the
empire great again
you know we need to act in such in such
a way and do these things
you know just as for the rebel alliance
like saying that the empire is awful
is the narrative that you use to stoke
your own ability
to fight a unwinnable war and then
somehow find a way to win at the end
and but to give voice to that other side
and like oh yeah no that guy absolutely
had
dozens of friends who i'm sure died in
one or both of those dead stars
and it's personal for that person and he
can't just kind of gloss over it
we've just never given that prospective
voice before
and i do think it's interesting i do
think it's it's complicated in a way
that star wars
is not usually um it's it's morally
ambiguous
in a way that it normally doesn't travel
um a couple thoughts from here in chat
101 guitar lessons says what about the
tiny baby handcuffs how many toddler
sized people do they
have in handcuffs in order to just have
cuffs to fit grogoo
well that sounds like something like
dante and randall would say yeah what
was your take on the baby
on the baby handcuffs were they also
meant to like suppress his horse powers
or they just
keep his hands down so he can't use the
force i mean i
i mean they were all glowy so i got the
feeling there was some kind of
of dampener effect but also do you know
how to build that
unless you've been keeping lots of
[ __ ] fourth babies
um which apparently they have because
you know
that's that's their whole mission if you
want these four sensitive
you know infants or creatures around the
cosmos
drain their blood and use it to make new
[ __ ] so
they might have it like you know maybe
it's a one size fits all maybe they got
a whole [ __ ] closet
of barry sized handcuffs just for people
who can do a little mojo with their
hands yeah they're like look man
the galaxy's full of all shapes and
sizes you know we're the empire we got
cuffs for all
true believer true believer says uh dave
filoni
started down the road of humanizing the
first order in star wars resistance
um so there you go i i confess i'm not
uh i don't go deep on the cartoons as
deep as i should
um and now we're getting the cartoons in
the shows in the live action
uh which is amazing um
the the only the only knit that i would
have to pick
with the the final episode is that i
kind of hope
that the the cg of luke skywalker was a
little bit better
um the first time i watched it it didn't
bother me at all the second time it's
like yeah
no like a deep fake would have been
better than this
like why why don't they do a deep fake
i don't understand i don't know like it
it
it seems as if it's like the long way
around to do a thing that the internet
is figuring how to do cheaply and
quickly
and like than that
it is like it's strange as i watched it
like because there's about
i would say eight shots of them maybe
ten max of cuts
to luke skywalker and stuff
and um you know some
work better than others um
but it is kind of like you know you see
those videos online those deep fakes
where you're like jesus man i [ __ ]
like put
vince vaughn in a [ __ ] robert de niro
movie or some [ __ ] like that where you
like can't believe how convincing it
[ __ ] looks
but i saw credit at the end which i
think i remember seeing
in rogue one as well um legacy
effects that means when they go back
and you know [ __ ] with duplicate
someone from the old ass movies there's
a whole [ __ ] department head
in charge of essentially bringing
you know young the young characters back
even though they're old at this point
yeah i mean i i think it's it's the same
technology they use in the irishman
to make everybody you know 50 years
younger and you know that worked
through varied you know degrees of
success yeah
look i i don't know about that i think
they were much more successful with what
they did in mandalorian than
than what they did in in the irishman
the irishman i was like wait
how old is he supposed to be i mean like
it looks like robert de niro got botox
that's
it
um but but yeah i mean it it is so
it is so wonderful a climax and we
talked about it like i think last
last episode that like i i and i said i
think we're gonna see the jedi
in the season finale um and yes we
theorized any number of ones they still
think mace windu would have been cool
and i hope we do get mace windu at some
point because there's no reason he
has to be dead when boba fett can
somehow be alive
um yes and let's talk about that what a
what a wonderful i mean it wasn't time
this way because nobody knows when
people are going to die but of course
uh as we know jeremy bullock who
originated the role of the fat and
empire strikes back and returned the
jedi many years ago he was the physical
form of boba fett not the the voice of
boba fett not even back then
before they changed it to what's his
name the guy who plays him now
tomorrow all right morrison um
jeremy bullock was one of those rock
star names of my childhood like david
prowse peter mayhew
one of the men behind the mask uh so i
knew
that name forever he's also though in
empire strikes back not as boba fett
um at one point he is the imperial if i
remember correctly jc might be able to
back me up
he is the imperial officer that
is escorting princess leia when she's
like luke it's a trap
i think that's going to be ebola double
dude is that correct
yeah that's correct i i win my old
star wars trivia games um yeah i always
remember that that was like a cool thing
when i was a kid like
he's he's him and he's he's him um
but in a in a a week uh where we lost
uh such an integral part of the star
wars franchise
um and we lost the guy who played boba
fett originally
um how what a what a almost fitting
poetic ending to the episode to see
boba fett sitting on the throne of jabba
the hutt
completely unexpected they haven't done
a ps
scene yet have they is that the first
one
um they did one before i can't remember
which episode it was jc i'm sure can can
pipe in with what with what it was
um but but yeah it is it is so fitting
for for jimmy bullock who have seen boba
fett be resurrected
and reinserted and in many ways
reclaimed
by star wars before he passed because i
mean jeremy bullock was incredibly
popular on the fan circuit like he would
pictures with every kid and sign every
autograph and did so for
40 some odd years um but you know
there's always the like well the fed
died like a punk
except he completely didn't and now you
know
we should all live long enough to see
ourselves be re-inserted
to a to a friend of glory if uh if so
much to that
particular part of your life have been a
little bit blemished but
yeah and for suddenly to be living in a
world where we're getting the book of
boba fett
as probably you know
functionally if not technically season
three of the mandalorian is going to be
the book of boba fett
um here's a note from just shay saying
kevin the new song
that music that played when luke arrived
was to show
luke isn't a kid anymore he's a
grandmaster jedi hero yeah
totally i agree that's what i was saying
i was like of course i would have liked
that's the theme of adventure of young
luke skywalker but i said this music was
much more somber like this guy is you
will bring the captain
captain solo and the wookie to me guy um
yeah man uh just i i don't i
i can't remember where and if
but in a world where this information is
now out there
uh about the book of boba coming next
year it's
december 2021. somebody had
told me recently i forget who i was
talking to but there was talk about like
oh no there's a whole [ __ ] boba thing
going on that nobody knows about and i
was like
what and i was i did not know that it
was going to be
[ __ ] announced um i didn't know what
was going i mean
all i heard was they had shot a separate
boba thing
apparently that's what they've been
doing man
how ingenious what a [ __ ] you want to
talk about a killer idea for a spin-off
like back in the 70s they were like i
know laverne and shirley
[ __ ] that man like a book of boba
oh my god like it's almost like they did
the mandalorian
just to get to that [ __ ] spin-off and
be like here's your [ __ ] boba fett
show um how awesome was it to see
the fate of bib fortuna not the
ultimate fate at the hands of of boba
fett but
that in jabba's absence this
[ __ ] rose
and became the man he went from being
like
the interpreter his little [ __ ] major
domo guy
to literally being the the head of the
house of hut
man and sitting there and he put on some
weight and [ __ ] and he had his staff
like his action figure had the [ __ ]
staff and [ __ ]
so i loved when he i i honestly did not
piece together
what was about to happen like i saw the
shot of the palace and i was like
holy [ __ ] what's going on here and then
when you cut inside i was like oh
[ __ ] man how awesome and then all of a
sudden
it got even more awesome everything
everything escalated in that [ __ ] end
credit scene we were like
that rocks that rocks that
[ __ ] rocks and then they just ended
the season oh my god it was magic
it makes up for both that just like
ultimately piecing out as they
invade um gideon's [ __ ] light cruiser
we're like i'm gonna shoot a couple tie
fighters and i'm just jumping away
good luck everybody have fun storming in
the castle all i was with the ride
how awesome was their fight too um where
like their him and the lady mandalorian
are going
back and forth and then she flips him
and he gets up and they both turn on
their [ __ ] flamethrowers
that just cancel each other out it was
really [ __ ] good yeah man that he
i mean peyton reid directed the [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of that john favreau wrote the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of it
and uh peyton reed did a phenomenal
[ __ ] job i'm a big fan of the ant-man
movie so
yeah not surprising um and ant-man
and all the marvel movies are so uh like
it's smart of them to go grab marvel
directors because like
tonally they are very similar
joyous they're not dark even when
there's you know bad things or darkness
happening it's never
all that [ __ ] dark man there's
there's fun to it
and uh those marble cats they really
know how to pull that off
i was just gonna jump in and say had
boba not taken off
it would have been a really awkward
scene at the end when luke showed up
and bubba would have been like hey
didn't you just wasn't i just
you're the sarlacc thing dick what if he
wanted revenge what if he was just like
i'm gonna [ __ ] kill that jedi
um yeah man it was [ __ ] it was dope
uh i i have no idea
where they're gonna go with it i wonder
if they'll just leave them on tattooing
and have the adventures there
but seeing that [ __ ] just
sitting on
jabba's thrown bro i had no idea
technically jabba had a throne like in
my if they always called it the throne
room the palace throne room but like
he's just sitting on a platform so it
never occurred to me
as a [ __ ] throne but once i saw boba
fett sitting there like
obviously in a chair that hasn't been
there when jabba used to be there
the clear [ __ ] you know impression is
like oh no
boba fett's on a [ __ ] throne how
badass is that like one of the greatest
splash page images in [ __ ] star wars
history
pulling back and looking at that dude
[ __ ] sitting there with dead bodies
all around them
and then they cut and [ __ ] tell you
there's more next christmas you're like
oh [ __ ]
how fantastic is that it would not
you know given that we got luke
skywalker which i didn't think we would
get um and i don't think we're going to
see any more of unless it's to return
grogu
you know because he doesn't feel like
he's now i want to ask you about like i
got the distinct impression at the end
of this
that we were seeing you know like
not just the end of a season the end of
a chapter but the end of an era
um it feels like going forward it's not
going to be
the mando and baby yoda show it's going
to be
mandalorian and you know maybe he'll run
into [ __ ]
grogu down the road or adventures will
involve but
i don't think i i like if what it felt
like was like this is
an ending and and of course like in a
world where luke skywalker just came and
picked the [ __ ] kid up
unless they do some sort of crazy time
jump or something like that it's like
he can't just be checking in on [ __ ]
grogu every week because
that's expensive to get mark hamill
to show up every week and young up and
[ __ ] like that they better put sebastian
stan
on the payroll and [ __ ] just recast
so
i you know it feels like this not like
this is the end
is this the end for baby yoda but it
feels like
he's well you know it feels like it is
an underlining reminder of like
the show's not called the mandalorian
and and grogu
it's called the mandalorian and he's
going to continue
his adventures this one happened to be
two seasons long
but i get the distinct impression that
yeah that's we're seeing kind of
the end of grogu and the the the book of
boba fett allows you a really nice break
if you needed to just like hey we're
gonna do this for eight episodes
and then when we return back to the
mandalorian it can be
five years forward it can be you know
two years are gonna be ten years
whatever they want it to be it seems as
if
you know at the very least the story is
pointing towards
you know bokeh tan wants a dark saber
and now the only person currently who
can wield it is the mandalorian and she
wants it and he
will happily give it to her but just
can't and so
well they say she's got to beat him but
does she gotta kill him can't she just
beat him up
i don't know or somebody else it seems
as if maybe death has to be involved but
maybe not
i don't know but somebody else could
beat mando and then she could kill that
person
um unclear but they seem to be on a bit
of a collision course
but i also wonder if part of the boba
fett show is
he might not like luke skywalker that
much
but there is one person who totally
actually killed him
who is actually in this timeline 100
alive
and that's um one solo
and if the book of boba is i'm gonna
[ __ ] settle my debts and clear the
decks until i can become a criminal
overlord
then there's one more person on that
motherfucker's list
i remember what yeah they're that guy's
never coming back
they even if they you know you parked a
money boat
and said well the age yeah look he's
he's made it very clear he's
done done done but then again so did
mark
so did mark and you know mark is
credited absolutely as reprisal
skywalker but there was also
double for jedi who came in to do
i think all of that fight stuff yeah
well i would i would absolutely
say so i mean look mark's mark looks
great for his age but
i i don't think mark could move like
that anymore they needed a guy who could
go in there and
pluckily deftly move in a way that you
know mark as a guy who's in his
60s i believe at this point like you
know maybe
it's not not not how it's going to
happen uh but
so that i you know completely got but i
think
the way i understand the credits
that was him and he definitely at least
did the voice
i don't know if they like just to had
him standing there and de-aged him or
something like that
but he's definitely doing the voice
which they probably had to pitch up or
something like that
get closer to his old voice although
he's a very talented voice actor
wouldn't surprise me if he could pitch
himself up
that's true my god you're absolutely
right um one of the
things i've thought like luke skywalker
shows up and i was in [ __ ] tears luke
skywalker
snaps on a [ __ ] the green lightsaber
and [ __ ] takes out
all of the dark troopers you know i'm
i'm
cheering at [ __ ] five in the morning
at my laptop and [ __ ]
rolling tears that they could have you
know
credits right then and there and they
would have owned everybody
and somehow even with all that they were
able to have
two really [ __ ] incredible moments um
with a puppet that surpassed
even luke showing up one
is um the moment where
uh den takes off his helmet
to show himself to grosgu
that's where i i like suddenly start
crying like i'm getting emotional
thinking about it now
it was incredibly beautiful and you know
as a storyteller i should have seen that
moment coming
and as it started happening i was like
of course of course
but [ __ ] man it was so well executed if
not
absolutely elevated him touching his
little face
pedro pascal earning every [ __ ] dime
he makes for the few shots that he takes
off his
helmet and he's there for uh conveying
like true [ __ ] warmth and and
amazement
for this little creature who he just
spent like all these adventures with and
knowing that he's got to let him go and
stuff like that
um that was absolutely
beautiful stunning and then
um and this is going to be tough without
i'm going to try not to [ __ ] cry
the same little guy who brought us all
into star wars like because if you go
back to 77 before there's a baby yoda or
a yoda
or a bb-8 or anything what
captured every child and every adult's
imagination
was r2d2 simple little trash can looking
droid
who beeped and whistled and captured
everybody's
hearts the original baby yoda the
original weigh-in
you know the first taste is free and
that first
taste was r2d2 so to
indicate to show grow goo being a little
scared to go with luke skywalker
and then do that sick ass [ __ ] reveal
of r2d2 coming in just you know punching
you right in your nostalgic
balls um was almost like going
like that's the same way you got into
star wars as a kid
that's how grogu is gonna get into star
wars now
yoda uh r2d2 is the doorway
even for that character i thought that
was incredibly
[ __ ] special man like it shined a
light
on a character who didn't really have a
[ __ ] ton to do
in the you know the last trilogy and
stuff like and the last movie it was
barely there at all really felt like so
this was absolute [ __ ]
magic such a magic moment what not and
of course
the kid would be [ __ ] like
bemused you know he's he's [ __ ]
playing with that little
metal [ __ ] ball at the top of the
gear shift the whole [ __ ] series
of course something like r2d2 would
like draw his attention and whatnot and
that moment where r2d2
pulls in the third leg and then kind of
like bends to look down
at him and [ __ ] star wars magic right
there man
blissful that's the moment that got me
like i i
i was like i was just amazed and
impressed
at luke skywalker but like when r2 shows
up
like that's that's when the tears
started to roll in ways that i didn't
expect to happen
but you know to your point you're 100
right and there are two
is the is the gateway drug of star wars
and
just just to hear that [ __ ] the bleep
bloops
and just like oh oh you did it to me
again
check it out man there's a bunch of
chatter in the in this is why i love
doing the show because i don't think of
[ __ ] like
this never occurred to me but and you
know what really bums me out this
would have occurred to [ __ ] young kev
smith after he watched
mandalorian like 26 times but this new
generation they're [ __ ] on it
um richard adams who is one of many
people
expressing this very similar sentiment
sentiment ready
did r2d2 pull grogu
out of the jedi temple
remember the younglings got [ __ ]
slaughtered in the jedi temple
r2 was there was around was in that
world
and you know part of the joke for
[ __ ] months has now been
how did [ __ ] baby yoda get away when
anakin skywalker iced all the younglings
and [ __ ] like that
so right now there's i mean easily
40 people in chat who are like
hey man maybe r2d2 was the one that got
[ __ ] grogu out of there in the first
place and maybe this was a
a re-meeting now i doubt that was what
was being communicated in that scene
but [ __ ] did i like appreciate that
people were quick enough to be like
no no he might remember a thing or two
about that maybe he was involved with
something like that
thoughts uh i i could never put it
together and i'm sure jc
will will help to to correct me that
every that that grogu necessarily needed
to be in the jedi temple on coruscant
to survive the youngling massacre he
technically could have been
anywhere you know because he doesn't
have any training he's
just naturally forced powerful um
so he could have been anyplace else in
the cosmos and
and have been somehow in whoever
captured him and put him in the [ __ ]
ball
that the imp the empire is after um it's
cool
if he was on coruscant and r2 had
something to do with that
although i don't know if r2 would have
been there if he would have been with
anakin on uh on lava land
um in his ship i'm gonna say i don't
think r2 stood by
and watched anakin slaughter a bunch of
children
and then was like i'm going to save the
little green guy
uh you know i think r2 look
there could be a really great short film
in
like r2's choice where he
you know there's slaughtering younglings
everywhere and he can only rescue
one and who does he pick but baby yoda
youtube list i could have saved one more
thing
our two's list this uh somebody put put
this in chat i thought this was
interesting
um cure said uh i think grogu
just reminds r2 of yoda which would make
sense
r2d2 met yoda at this point in empire
strikes back and return of the jedi he's
been
and you know he wrestled with [ __ ]
yoda were you know over there i don't
think he liked yoda i don't think they
got along that well
yeah yeah so maybe he's looking at grogu
like not another one of these [ __ ]
things yeah
you're smaller i can squash you with
this third foot right here
the middle leg smash this is going to
you ain't hitting me with a stick one
day [ __ ] you
luke luke this guy's a thief he tried to
steal your lamp they're all
yeah no but then they're pointing out in
chat
i lost it who's somebody said uh r2
wouldn't have
memories of that because his memory was
wiped but
wait that's team three people two
members
yes memory was wiped but at the end of
one of the at the end of uh
revenge of the sith remember and what's
his name is like
and wipe the droid's memories wipe the
gold one's memories r2d2 keeps his
memories
is that canon they in the in revenge of
the sith
they wipe they say to wipe 3po but they
leave r2
when there's no line that says leave the
little one
no but they don't say wipe the droids
they say wipe the
protocol droid's memory or wipe the gold
one's memory
and then r2 and yeah so r2 has his
memory
intact how cool is this [ __ ] so he these
two dudes hang out together
and the one little guy is like remember
when all this [ __ ] happened and the big
guy's like
i don't know what you're talking about
you're a drunk again shut the hell up
stop making [ __ ] up
i didn't know that's [ __ ] up i wanted
to uh
point out that at the end of return of
the jedi
one of the last lines in the movie is
uh help me take this mask off i want to
look on you with my own eyes
and in this episode luke watches
a father take his mask off
to show his son his face for the first
time
that's [ __ ] beautiful i hadn't even
thought of that
he's standing there witnessing it and
whatnot that's good jc
good call um ooh that made that gave me
chills
um yeah man it was there's a moment too
where luke is holding grogu
and like grogu looks at him and he's
looking down at grogu
um which you know once again they could
have [ __ ] written a zillion lines of
dialogue something like i would have
done but instead they communicated it
beautifully with a performance and like
you could see it in luke's eyes
even if he has a cg you know kind of
character
that like oh my god there's another one
of these like
in his life yoda died not too long ago
right
like when does that when does return the
jedi happen five years
yeah so how sweet and moving for him his
buddy
his mentor his his master jedi master
um uh gone
and suddenly he meets a little version
of him
and that performance moment like
perfectly communicated that for me where
i was like
i know what's going on here i appreciate
your insistence on using the name grosgu
you got it like we're trying to make
fetch happen for real
um yeah man hands down
like you know one of
the top i would say
five star wars things ever
for me um
that was that was incredibly special
and it was a quite a gift
for like the you know bunch of people
who are like man
i wish i could have seen my luke scott
walker again
like the one that i grew up with that's
what a lot of people said after like
last jedi that like what happened he's
got
a beard and he's sad and this was a real
and and i
i loved that luke skywalker as well but
this
was indeed luke skywalker i [ __ ] grew
up with and i was so
happy to see him return what a gift like
you know the first thing i say to
favro if i ever see him in life is gonna
be
about the return of luke skywalker i
thought that took huge storytelling
balls
huge but you know what he earned it
after two seasons of this [ __ ] show
and i would say i would argue that this
is a perfect season
season two um
if of course he [ __ ] had the boss
pull it off he had the talent he had the
chops
he earned it we earned it as an audience
oh
i was gonna say oh go ahead mark sorry i
was just gonna say
it's so nice to see star wars executed
with a plan
you know i mean i think that there are
moments in the in the sequel trilogy
that i like um you know and i and i do
like last jedi i think more than some if
not most
um but i think that the grand failing of
those three movies is that there was no
consistent plan
to see any of them through they were
kind of making it up as you went
and the continuity wasn't there and and
a sense of escalation wasn't there
and there were there were warring sort
of philosophies on what star wars was
whereas the mandalorian is two guys
who got together and says you know would
be really cool like what if we made star
wars
and like did all the things and knew
where it was going
and brought in characters we thought can
amplified and make up new characters who
we thought would be cool
you know what if we and what if we did
you know the thing that that every
corporation talks about doing which is
find ways to to tell diverse stories
with diverse storytellers
but make it so that you barely notice it
just make it effortless you know it it
it doesn't
it doesn't go without at least me
commenting on that
the final sequence of the mandalorian is
four women storming a bridge
and killing everybody you know like
badass in the most badass version of
badassery
you know i think there's like one white
dude with a line
in that entire episode and you don't
care
because it's so great it's so great and
that's that's when
diversity works is when the audience
doesn't notice it and it just becomes
the fabric of the stories you're telling
and and they had a plan they knew where
they were going and they knew how to get
there
and they knew i don't know how soon they
knew they were going to get to luke
skywalker but they knew at some point
that
that jyn jardine and grogu were going to
part ways
they were like uh we're saving our one
white guy
for luke skywalker
we got one more guy white guy card to
play and guess which one it is
man i was just gonna echo what mark said
which was
you didn't even notice that star wars
gave you
the the the powerful
women here because it was built from
episode three of season one up to this
and not to [ __ ] on avengers end game
but in end game they kind of put it
right front and center in the camera
saying we're doing this
in star wars it just organically
happened and so it
went over so many people's heads that oh
for
15 minutes of this episode we just had
four diverse
badass women getting the job done
and you didn't even notice it because it
was so
seamlessly executed and built up
over you know eight hours which i
thought was great
it was very great let's be honest
there's so much [ __ ]
good in this series but particularly
the season finale episode that you
forget
stuff like that you know moment where
the
the women [ __ ] take on platoons of
stormtroopers and [ __ ]
ice them and [ __ ] like that and we also
didn't really speak about
giancarlo esposito's performance which
like
is pure classic movie villain
yeah he's doing so much with so little
and just like every scene with him in it
like every everything that feels like it
could be hammy
and seeing chewy and like mustache
poorly
becomes just [ __ ] stingy in class
like he's he's no good at that and it's
it's easy to say that he's the obvious
choice for your big bad because
he does that so incredibly well but like
there's this
this kind of slithery charm that he can
muster
that makes like even not even to say
that mop getting's a cardboard bad guy
but he could be in the hands of the
wrong actor and he's just he's
he's just leaning into it in ways that's
so much fun to watch
and how awesome is it that imperials are
just like
oh [ __ ] this like every one of them
every one of them are either trying to
bite down on a [ __ ] capsule
or this fucker's like [ __ ] it like it's
so
badass and something like like you never
saw in the original star wars trilogy
there was no moment where the rebels
came in and some [ __ ] was like
oh [ __ ] this it just took his own life
but more of that you know i'll take a
whole movie full of [ __ ] scared
imperials
taking their own lives rather than
facing [ __ ]
some uh some uh din
action or any of his friends um
giancarlo esposito just giving a clinic
on how to deliver um sci-fi
action dialogue and make it seem like
believable
and real with stakes like you know he's
just putting the same performance
it's so crazy as i sit there and watch
him i'll never i'm like i'm a huge do
the right thing fan i'm like that's
bugging out like the same guy who was
like
yo sal we're going to boycott your fat
pasta ass here's
off gideon yo sal how come you're gonna
brothers up on the wall
like that's marv gideon it's crazy um
[ __ ] jordans yo your jordans are
[ __ ] up
um he's he's like a brilliant choice man
like uh
you know once again favro is the man the
mind that brought us
uh robert downey jr as tony stark
and what a difference that made to you
know not just marvel studios but to the
world of entertainment
in general last 10 years of our lives
been
better because robert downey jr has been
[ __ ] tony
stark and [ __ ] like that marvel universe
grew
because it had a very strong spine in
tony stark
his casting instincts are [ __ ]
incredible man
just absolutely [ __ ] delightful and
how awesome that they let moff gideon
live
yeah they weren't just like yeah like oh
he's [ __ ] dead we had to kill him and
[ __ ] like that or he killed himself he's
like no he'll be back
yeah can't get rid of that dude he wants
joy um all right man did we cover
everything
in uh i'm looking in chat to see if
there's anything we didn't
we didn't cover uh nick kozan says the
scene with cara dune
trying to get her 60 caliber laser rifle
working was great in the elevator where
she's like bang bang
she's like excuse me and she the other
uh what's her name ducks
as it goes over her head um yeah
it was uh it was a fantastic episode i
think we've kind of
shot our wad on it man uh i give that if
if we're doing you know
numbers and scales of numbers that one's
[ __ ] hands down a 10 out of 10.
like i honestly didn't think you could
get better
than some of the episodes they did this
season where i was like what a
mind [ __ ] that was this was incredible
even their quiet episodes like they did
some
things that i've never seen done in a
star wars thing before
but this season finale man it was just
not just incredibly satisfying as a
to a star wars fan and if you're a fan
of mandalorian and stuff
but as a storyteller i was just like
my hat's off to you i never would have
had the balls to be like
i know luke skywalker like wouldn't that
be great like
luke is the obvious answer but like i
would just be like yeah but
too many things would make that hard and
thank god
that [ __ ] favreau was like i like
i made the jungle book i made lion king
like
i can make mark hamill look young enough
to bust a few lines get the [ __ ] out
that's [ __ ] yeah exactly that shot of
them together
in the elevator like right before the
door is closed and the credits [ __ ]
roll and [ __ ]
it's like a real star wars moment man a
real like star wars
[ __ ] finale and [ __ ] and i was so
glad they went out on that
it was such a great visual such a great
image there's luke there's r2 and
there's
grogu in his hands man and it's like the
doors close
this book is done so next time we come
back to mandalorian
um well you're not gonna be protecting
the little baby again it's not like
they're gonna run that [ __ ]
scam so who knows what it is next
but i look forward to the moment when
mando
is in over his head and all seems lost
and
the what the rescue that shows up
is grogu kind of all growed up
yeah i don't know how cool about that
him talking like i don't know if i want
to ever hear grogu talk i like hearing
them cool and [ __ ] like that
like i love whatever there's the moment
when grogu
is [ __ ] like force choking
[ __ ] out to get to the the
the state that the the the mendo's stuck
in
and the door opens and it's just grogu
and he says this is the way
that's all i [ __ ] need
um we didn't even talk about the we
called it we talked about it
weeks previous but it's like hey i bet
you that spear is gonna cross
you know swords with the dark saber and
[ __ ] sure enough
yeah they absolutely did it um and how
delightful
i i you know best guar steel is a
relatively new creation i believe
uh i've only heard about it for
mandalorian
because introducing the you know
uncuttable armor the you know nothing
can [ __ ] with this
the adamantium or the or the vibranium
of the star wars universe you know
i'm maybe it's not the most incredibly
original stroke of brilliance but like
i enjoy having that in that world they
never had that before there's
something like it's it's like throwing
kryptonite into star wars you're like oh
right on man this
is a game change something can actually
hold up against a lightsaber
that's cool i i was told by some of my
mandalorian cosplay friends that besgar
has been
what they refer to their armor as for a
long time
but i do believe the
uh can't cut through it with a
lightsaber is
i it's it wasn't invented in this
but it has been referenced this is the
the boldest they've made it agreed
uh peter common com ninos in chat says
book of boba is a separate show it's not
season three of mandalorian
we know we didn't say that it was um we
were just saying we were just talking
maybe you missed the part where we said
nothing like that whatsoever but yeah we
we know it's a
whole separate series man they didn't
announce [ __ ]
like remember just like a few days
before last week they were like
here's every [ __ ] star wars thing you
could shake a lightsaber at and then
the credits of this they're like by the
way here's one more
yeah look at our our lovely reticence to
tell you we
we managed to hold off giving you the
biggest star wars gun
which is [ __ ] a boba fett show
that is that is some restraint it really
is
um all right that's the mandalorian
appreciation hour
and a half
there must be like is there any other
news in this
world right now i mean there's a couple
things we could talk about or we could
just do q and a
none of it's like that awesome nothing
yeah nothing's really
happening right this seemed like the
biggest news of the week
like clooney once again shits on batman
and robin because
that's his move it's not surprising yeah
i mean physical pain to watch he says
um all right then yeah i think mark's
right there's no need to do news
we don't really have much news to talk
about so that means
that we move on to the finale of our
show the final section ladies and
gentlemen
uh the q a for which we bring jc
back uh and jc will give you
give your questions three to me and he
and we will answer thee uh don't forget
ladies and gentlemen uh
if you're looking for jay and salam bob
type christmas [ __ ]
go to if you want to
give the gift of a membership in that
kevin smith club to that kevin smith
club fan in your life
go to thatkevinsmithclub.com mark's got
a shirt
to sell where are you sending him i do
embattled embattledclothing.com
you can you can get yourself a be humble
t-shirt or sweatshirt or stickers or
what have you
you can still get a resistance as
fertile shirt um but yeah it's all there
go get some fusion code mark 15 say 15
off your first order and of course don't
forget ladies and gentlemen our
sponsor this evening is good folks it
keeps
they want you to keep your [ __ ] hair
it's not [ __ ] simple
go to keeps.com keps dot com slash
fat man and you're gonna get yourself uh
some free shipments
like amazon a lot of i got a website
where we sell [ __ ] and people like how
come you don't [ __ ] do free shipping
like amazon it's like cause i'm not
[ __ ] billionaire like jeff bezos
i would think that much is obvious yeah
i like to pay the people who work for me
i also don't [ __ ] have an island in
the turks and caicos or whatever [ __ ]
and
that's another reason i'm not jeff bezos
um all right jc we got questions here
yeah we got some good ones
um the trash panda
wants to know star wars has a long
history
of redeeming its villains if you could
do a redemption story for
any fictional villain who would it be
and how would you make us root for them
wow i mean boy they just
they redeemed boba fett without
redeeming them
most recently i thought that was rather
impressive i mean if anything they just
made them more badass and stuff
um so it's not like they you know like i
was gonna say
you know you know what would be a great
[ __ ] redemption story bib fortuna but
not anymore
[Laughter]
um there goes my [ __ ] mini series i
was hoping to do the bib fortuna but
he's out oh for tuna um
hmm i mean they've done they've done
some good work on lex luthor
like you know who had been very not
gonna call it for a long time
oh wait this doesn't have to be a star
wars character no yeah any
any villain oh because i was like
there's like only three bad people in
star wars
it's like darth vader and he turned uh
i was like i don't know thrawn uh
anybody who's been bad that you could
turn yeah
the shark in jaws oh bruce redeem him
just like get people understand he's
like i'm hungry
i'm not a monster i'm just hungry
um no who who could one redeem
uh there was a moment in well this is
not a [ __ ] plug cause i got no skin
in the game but since it's sitting right
here
there is a moment in one of these kills
somebody they're so
thick grant morrison jla stories
where um uh
the joker feels
remorse for everything he's done he like
he uh gets a hold of the world of gog
and
is confronted with like ultimate truth
or whatever
and rationality returns to him for
a [ __ ] second and there's this
beautiful panel i think howard porter
drew it but definitely written by grant
morrison
where joker realized has this you know
it's always madness and [ __ ] like that
for this one two panels he has
perfect sanity and clarity
and he breaks down going my god
all the people like he realizes
how many [ __ ] people he's killed and
it nearly breaks his brain
again or whatever [ __ ] i just thought
that was a cool moment
but i don't know if you want to redeem
the joker
yeah i mean i think redemption
redemption isn't necessarily that
interesting for me as much as
understanding you know like if you could
if you could
if you could make us understand why this
person does the things they do
um there's something so much more
interesting to me about that
um like killmonger like you know
killmonger made you understand and they
didn't redeem them although that would
be a good
redemption story because in a world
about it on the show um
nope am i back yes you you already
dropped for a second
yeah because i opened my things um in a
world where
you know they're not doing t'challa you
know if they if killmonger became the
new black panther and that was a [ __ ]
redemption story
that'd be that'd be great but they he
died i don't know how they can pull that
off
no did he though you see that's i don't
know why i'm in the movie business
because i'm such a literalist i'm like
well he doesn't know
he can't come back just like you know
well luke skywalker he could never show
up for this show
i mean like winter soldier is is also a
really good one because he begins as a
villain
you know and then eventually like we
understand his perspective and he
changes and he tweaks we get to be
manipulated and all that stuff um
i think i would for some reason i i went
straight to sher khan
from the jungle book um you know because
like maybe he's upset at maybe being
like the last of his
his [ __ ] pack that they've been
hunted almost to extinction
and he's different than everybody else
and he's a [ __ ] panther and the
panther height is incredibly valuable
and he's just like here's why this guy
is the way he is
you know and if you understand that you
know maybe he doesn't necessarily want
to be evil he's also like bruce
our animal villains let's redeem our
animal villains where it's like listen
all i do is swim and eat
i don't i don't like want necessarily to
kill these particular people
but i got to do shark's got a shark
panther's got a panther
and i'm running out of places to panther
so maybe this if i kill this kid they'll
stop hunting us so much because they'll
be afraid of the jungle again i
understand his wants and needs
it's not redemption but it's at the very
least empathy
um and i like and i'll i'll back that
play because i like the name sheer khan
who's playing khan wasn't idris elba in
the movie yeah
yeah and alice hello alice
alice i'm not going to eat you anymore
alice
come on mowgli it's not so bad
it'll be quick we're canceling the
apocalypse
um all right those are two answers
there you go what else we got henrik and
chat
said redeem the scriptwriters of game of
game of thrones season 8 which i know
i think that's impossible i don't know
i'm not i'm not that good a writer to be
able to [ __ ] get those guys out of
that hole
uh boy oh boy it's like with all due
respect
you know to be fair they were on what
season seven of that and mandalorian's
on season two or whatever the [ __ ] but
like
this mando show knows how to [ __ ] do
a season finale [ __ ] man
i was there was no dissatisfaction
whatsoever but you know what to be fair
game of thrones did many season finales
that were
were great it was just the series finale
that was little
yeah they didn't stick that landing yeah
you know what
i wouldn't have even gotten that far i
wouldn't have gotten off the [ __ ]
pilot so
he did way better than i for as many
people that always [ __ ] about that last
season i'm like i couldn't have done it
you know uh all right
we got another question this one's from
rob
buck who wants to recast
clerks using only star wars characters
uh okay well jay and sal and bob are
definitely
uh c-3po and r2d2
um luke is
dante han is randall
um well it's either caitlin or
veronica's princess leia
let's go with veronica
um hmm
um the death star contractor guy is
lobot
no i don't know
[Laughter]
i feel like i hit the main ones i think
you i think you got it
yeah uh that's a good question but mark
didn't get to play on that one
yeah i wasn't even gonna hide rules jc
where we used to have to [ __ ]
ask something that only both of us can
answer
oh i thought mark could jump in on that
i was thinking more like
yeah you cast a [ __ ] four characters
pretty quick uh okay this one
uh we'll stick with uh another star wars
jimmy greer
he says uh luke is the galaxy's best
uber driver
what other profession would luke
skywalker be great at
outside of jedi like let's say uh he
left the moisture farm
to seek his fortune but never met
obi-wan what
what job does luke skywalker get in a
galaxy far
far away commercial pilot
freight freight driver like he's good in
a ship
um and you know like ex-military men
they always wind up
doing like united airlines and [ __ ] like
that right so
i'd imagine he'd segue from a guvie job
to a comfy job in the private sector
involving his skill set and whatnot um
you know he's man of peace as we saw and
last jedi he's just looking to drink
that
titty milk and hang out by himself and
stuff so
probably you know he ain't looking for
no more adventure i think he's content
to do
like he does uh he does the
the burbank to vegas round
four day four nights a week uh one night
he does a stay
and he deadheads back is star wars
ruined for you kids
that's why i'm not in charge that's why
they're giving it
to good
like that's what happened to the hero of
the galaxy i'm like he wanted a steady
job
quiet it was either that or air traffic
controlling and he went with that
it's the clarence comes to obi-wan
kenobi it's like
i want to know what my life would be
like if i wasn't in it well meet luke
skywalker
pilot from moss heisley to the moisture
farms
and he's got that kind of personality
man who would be like a southwest pilot
who's just like uh
hey we're our land and everybody's alive
and everybody applauds for the plane
like
he's the context for flying i'm morphing
here my name is luke skywalker i've been
your pilot uh
don't forget to put up your seat backs
and tray tables and uh
thanks for flying with us thank you mike
no way bro no way it ends with
thank you for flying with us and may the
force be with you and then he gets
reprimanded for bringing religion into
his job all the time
they're like how many times do we have
to tell you this he's like hey
hey it's captain skywalker captain i got
the
[ __ ] badge right here oh yeah sure
buddy
captain skywalker i earned my wings
you know i did blow up the first death
star
i think he's a he could also be an
exterminator because he was really good
at bullseye
womp rats in his 316 back home and now
that's all he does
just like you got a wimp rat problem all
your boys luke skywalker
or he's good at flying but he's shitty
at landing
[Laughter]
so you know they don't they can't have
him as a southwest pilot and [ __ ]
um so instead yeah he's doing uh he's
crop dustin
he's crop dustin there you go and he
does aerial stunt shows on the fourth of
july
you know barnstorming if you will
but han says traveling through
hyperspace ain't like dustin crops boy
so maybe luke like because he doesn't
need honey he's like crop dusting would
be a good career
yeah he's like you know what [ __ ] that
guy nothing's like dust and crops
cause dust and crops is fun and that's
he decides to go back to being a farmer
don't we all go back to where we came
isn't that the point of life the
greatest to go
on to go on is to go far to go far as to
return
so i would say he's like yeah [ __ ] man
i'm ready to go
ready to go back to the sand planet
[ __ ] maybe open up a little shop
convenience store and tashi station sell
power converters
blue mill straight out the titty blue
mill
that i everyone loves that fresh milk
right they're like not really luke
i like it out of card it's like well you
ain't invited
until you take it straight off the album
called straight out of titty
uh close up magician like you've got
just enough of the force to be able to
make like cards and [ __ ] move around
like i can't lift
x-wings but i can make this coin
move across the room oh that'd be
amazing and instead of being like
you know all sorts of like bright-eyed
and innocent like he always was and [ __ ]
like that
he's become more like a han solo where
he's like i'm fleecing these pigeons
he's become like an artful dodger and
[ __ ] yoda appears to him in
spectral form and he's like wasting your
[ __ ] gifts you are
and he's like hey hey hey he's going i'm
going to drink you away little man
he [ __ ] pulled out his space liquor
listen i've got a hut right next to the
[ __ ] cantina i got all the titty milk
i can drink
but i don't need anything else so [ __ ]
you little dead man
and then um you get away with that so
long as in the third act he shows up you
know on the planet
and ghost fights the bad guy because
then
uh i i uh i i thought about last jedi a
bunch
obviously when i watched this episode of
the mandalorian because that was the
last time
we saw luke and
so there's obvious parallels
one could make um
what if anything and this is all
conjecture
what if anything in watching that
episode and watching
you know luke unleashed um
do you think favreau feels about
the prequels
um i mean it again pure conjecture
i absolutely yeah we we cannot pretend
to know what favorite thinks about very
much
um but it seems as if he senses missed
opportunities
um you know and ways to to
earn fan service in a way that makes it
not feel so much like you've been
chummed
um but more like you feel like you've
been rewarded
he sounds like every fan or he occurs to
me as every fan on the internet
who's like oh i would have done this
this is what i would have done this is
what i would have done
and not people that [ __ ] on a thing were
like it [ __ ] sucks and i hated it but
like
yeah it was good but like if they had
done this it would have been cool
he he feels like that but he just got
the power to actually
make it happen like i suppose the rest
of us sitting around here going like
oh no luke big dustin crops you know
he's like
luke dusts crops it actually
makes a thing can can i stir the pot and
i'm sure i'm going to piss some people
off
but in both the ahsoka episode and out
of luke skywalker's mouth in this
episode
he says uh talent without training is
meaningless
and that comes out of ahsoka's mouth and
luke's mouth
and i can't help but think that it
relates
to who's that directed at i can't help
but think that that's
uh a little wink and a nod to our
superhero jedis that
uh appear in the sequel trilogy without
any training
is that right i i i mean i didn't write
those lines but
uh dave filoni and john favreau did it's
it's insightful man i wouldn't have
thought i wouldn't have seen that
uh somebody pointed out that i said uh
the uh sequel uh prequels but i meant of
course the sequels
um i was saying what did he think what
is what what is favreau
we're trying to figure out what john's
take on the
the sequel trilogy was um but i like
what
what jc just said that kind of makes
sense i hadn't thought about that
um okay our final question the evening
jc what do we got
all right as we uh wrap up probably our
last show before
uh the holidays is that right i figured
we'd get maybe one more off but i could
be wrong
well christmas i think it's thursday or
friday
yeah which we're also getting wonder
woman 84.
so if we do a show next saturday which
would be the 26th
we can talk about wonder woman if that
sounds good
we're just planning live on air now but
yeah
so that's every week from now but that
that's good we could totally talk about
wonder woman and [ __ ]
that's right let's drop the day before i
can i can have some thoughts
about you know a year-end list which i
like to do
you do mark likes a list pull it to the
list i mean
what did you see [ __ ] three movies
let me rank the episodes of ted lasso
from one to ten it's like well
yeah they're all really good um
but i think that the ten best things i
saw this year
i think is is pretty cool and that lets
it be video games and tv shows and
movies and
hopefully wonder woman 84 will make that
list um
but uh but yeah i think that'll be fun
um yeah because i don't expect there to
be much news
the day after christmas agreed
i agree um all right wait did we hit our
last question now last
last question uh comes from jim chapman
and uh jim is interested in knowing um
what property or show would you
love to see a holiday special if you
were tasked
with creating one so we got a long time
ago
lego or we got star wars holiday special
we got lego star wars holiday special
we're getting a guardians of the galaxy
holiday special what would you guys want
to do
rick and morty
they've had santa but like a full flat
out christmas episode
um because the chris the holidays could
be a really depressing time
as well for some people and i think the
rick sanchez character
perfectly captures um
people who are you know get depressed um
so it'd be interesting
to see what dan harmon and justin
roiland did with
with the you know it's this
the season is the reason and that kind
of [ __ ]
uh we've seen them touch on jesus as
well and jesus is a big part of
christmas for some people and stuff
um so yeah i i i would take a rick and
morty christmas special
off the top of my head what about you
mark i would like
a back to the future christmas special i
think
i think you take the delorean back to
jerusalem
in the year zero zero zero zero and meet
jesus says he's being born and you
[ __ ] go to the manger and then like
you got a
plutonium in you know the middle east
in year zero um i think time travel to
your point
like helps you uh you know gives you a
lot of leeway and a lot of latitude let
you do a lot of things but i think
doc brown and marty um back in time
to witness the beginning of christianity
could be kind of fun
um i wonder
i wonder like how that would do at the
box office because number one you're
like you're getting another back to the
[ __ ] future movie and people like are
you [ __ ] kidding me
i never thought that would happen and
they're like but
it's it's like you know it's so
religious it might as well be an episode
of veggie tales
like it's remember veggie tales kids the
tomato and the cucumber they love christ
that's what this shit's gonna be
so you sure you want it i'd go for it
i'd be like [ __ ] yeah let's leave
let's see him meet not only meet baby
jesus but save his [ __ ] life that'd
be dope
hey say one of the wise men who gets
like [ __ ] shanghai on the
and then like doc brown has to be one of
the three wise men
you know bringing something to the
manger um
and then they gotta save them from i
don't know romans i know romans aren't
in it yet but
no they'll work they'll work romans can
be back
[ __ ] romans i um i did that
sopranos thing last night and after i
was done i said to my wife i was like
let's rewatch all the sopranos so i just
started re-watching
mr brown i'm almost at the end of season
one today and um
at one point they talk about uh the
romans
like uh when they're trying to get the
guy shake the guy down and divorce the
dude's wife and
and he's like we'll give you a piece of
the motel business or something like
that
and the guy like brings up the story of
masada where he's just like
he's like you know uh for two years
the you know a thousand israelites
took masada and then you know didn't
surrender to the romans and then finally
took their own lives and stuff like that
and he's like and where do romans now
and tony soprano goes where do romans
um all right let's what if we did
a christmas carol starring the
ghostbusters
so you have the ghost of christmas past
present and future
with peter venkman trying to figure out
the whole ghost dynamic and like do they
actually go after
you know uh to try to save what bob
cratchit or
you know they're they're like hired by
scrooge to
to to stop these ghosts from haunting
him
i look uh i like your first pitch i'm
gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna add to it the uh i think
our three ghosts should be three
ghostbusters
and you know our scrooge should be
bill murray playing the role again but
as peter venkman this time
and so your goals of past present and
future would be
uh rey um egon and
winston that's
apparently the chat is hollering at me
because they did it in the ghostbusters
cartoon
so not i guess not an original idea
but james james ratliff in chat was like
they called it scrooge bill murray was
screwed
we know scrooge is one of my favorite
[ __ ] movies man
and i like the idea of bill murray and
scrooge
carrying the ghostbusters to get rid of
the ghosts who come and visit him
oh that'd be amazing cross is over it's
multiverse
yup it's all the rage now kids
um the murray verse the murray verse
uh some cats are calling for a game of
thrones holiday special
some cats in chat are calling for
legolas and gimli um
there's a few people looking for jay and
silent bob i'll back that [ __ ] play
i can know a guy i can talk to a guy
about that and [ __ ]
um all good ideas
all good ideas um
does that answer that's the last
question is it i think that's it my
friend
oh my god we're out of content kids it's
that
terrible time when there's nothing left
to talk about until next week and next
week we're gonna have
something to [ __ ] talk about for sure
man wonder woman 1984
dropping on hbo christmas eve at [ __ ]
midnight which i guess technically is
christmas morning
i'm staying up watching the [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of that man i don't care if i watch
it on my phone or a big ass tv in my
house
i'm going to enjoy the [ __ ] out of that
and we'll
gather on saturday um i guess roughly
the same time a week from now
yeah and uh chit chat about that and
[ __ ]
christmas and the meaning of christmas
and we'll read from the bible
a little bit and but the night after
christmas went all through the house
um how about that kids did you have a
good time today
did you enjoy yourselves sitting around
talking about oh somebody said mark when
galewski said
calvin and hobbes have animated
christmas special
i have no i no idea how much i wanted
that until i just saw that
it is so surprising there's never been
calvin and hobbes animated stuff
bill watterson was very tight with that
he didn't apparently want to do any of
that stuff
yep love it um what a good idea one of
the reasons i love doing this show
is because not only do we get to sit
here and geek about things we love and
fan out over things that we adore um you
get to
listen to a bunch of other people do the
same thing man you realize how similar
we all are with our goofy ideas and how
things that make us happy and whatnot
uh this show is one of those things that
makes me happy man
happy bright spot in a terrible terrible
year of 2020.
uh there is no show without uh jc
plugging us into the internet give it up
for jc andrews usually helping him out
when we're there live and in person but
i think jc is home right now
um but there's absolutely no show
without the this this this guy
this [ __ ] this guy
there it is this guy right there
uh give it up for the marvelous mark
bernard ladies oh
thank you sir thank you very much uh and
that ladies and gentlemen
is uh fat man beyond for this week i'm
kevin smith
i'm mark bernard tune in saturday next
saturday
same fat time same fat channel
smodcast.com or
youtube.com kevin smith this is the way
you